en el último vídeo de hipérbolas no tuve
la oportunidad de hacer ejemplos
concretos así que haré eso ahora
así que digamos que tengo la hipérbola
de cuadrada sobre 4 - x cuadrada sobre
no sé déjame pensar en un buen número
vamos a decir x cuadradas sobre 9 es
igual a 1 así que la primera cosa que
hay que descifrar de shaper bola es una
de sus asientos y una vez más yo siempre
olvidó las fórmulas así que siempre
intentó resolver para allá y ver qué
pasa cuando x se aproxima al infinito
negativo o positivo
así que si resuelve es para y puede
sumar x cuadradas sobre 9 ambos lados y
obtienes ye cuadrada sobre 4 lo que es
igual a equis cuadrada sobre 9
+ 1
ahora puedes multiplicar por 4 en ambos
lados y obtienes de cuadrada igual a 4
entre 9
por equis cuadrada más 4
ahora tomamos las raíces cuadradas de
ambos lados y ya es igual a más o menos
la raíz cuadrada de 4 entre 9 por equis
cuadrada más 4
y no podemos simplificar más esto pero
podemos pensar en lo que esto se
aproxima cuando x se aproxima
al
infinito positivo o negativo
entonces mientras extiende a más menos
infinito que es esto a que se aproxima
esto aquí se está aproximando la gráfica
pues entonces ya es aproximadamente
igual a
sólo el cuadrado de este término porque
este término se vuelve súper grande y
relativamente a este término este
término empieza a importar menos menos y
por eso es que llegamos cerca y cerca a
las a sin total porque cuando este
número es un trillón un google entonces
este número es insignificante
cuando sacamos la raíz cuadrada casi
sólo sacamos la raíz cuadrada de esto y
entonces sólo estarás un poco más arriba
de la gráfica porque tienes este extra
más 4 ahí entonces mientras te aproximas
a + menos infinito esta ecuación es
aproximadamente igual a
- raíz cuadrada de 4 entre 9 por equis
cuadrada
entonces eso nos da que es
aproximadamente igual al más menos la
raíz cuadrada de cuatro novenos que es 2
entre 3 la raíz cuadrada de 4 entre la
raíz cuadrada de 9 por x así que estas
son las a sin total hay dos líneas aquí
una es igual a dos tercios de equis y la
otra es igual a menos dos tercios de x
así que dibujemos esas dos líneas déjame
dibujar mis ejes éste será mi eje y y
este es el eje x déjame cambio de color
para hacer las cosas más interesantes
así que déjame dibujar la primera donde
ya es igual a dos tercios de x así que
te elevas dos por cada tres que avances
así que déjame dibujar eso
entonces si esto es 1 2
este será un punto de la línea y déjame
dibujar la línea tiene que pasar por el
origen y
me aseguraré que pase de esta manera y
continuaré así
entonces esta es una sim total y la otra
es donde es igual a menos dos tercios x
y bajaríamos 2 por cada 3 que avanzamos
el punto estaría aquí
déjame dibujarla sin tota pasa por el
origen
listo hemos dibujado nuestras asín total
ahora la pregunta es si va a abrir hacia
la derecha izquierda arriba o abajo hay
dos maneras en las que podemos pensar en
eso y pensé que la manera que será más
intuitiva para ti es qué pasa cuando x
es igual a cero cuando x es igual a cero
esto desaparece y solo nos queda de
cuadrada entre 4 es igual a 1
de cuadrada es igual a 4 y que es igual
a más menos 2
de tal manera que los puntos 0 + menos
dos están en esta gráfica entonces 0 + 2
es este punto de aquí y 0 - 2
es este punto de acá
eso por sí mismo es más que una pista
para saber qué abre aquí abajo y aquí
arriba porque esto nunca una hipérbola
nunca cruzar a la sas into estás no es
como que puede ir por acá y cruzar ésta
sin total
entonces ya sabemos que la gráfica de
este hipérbola puedes probar otros
puntos si quieres solo para verificar va
a verse algo como esto así que esta
hipérbola va a ir muy cerca
pero nunca la toca del otro lado va a ir
muy cerca
pero nunca toca la parte de arriba va a
ir muy cerca pero nunca nunca nunca toca
y del otro lado va a ir muy cerca
infinitamente cerca pero nunca la toca
entonces esto es cómo se verá la
hipérbola y lo hice tan solo viendo si x
podía ser igual a 0 y te invito a que
veas qué pasa cuando ya tiende a cero no
tendrás una solución y eso tiene sentido
porque esta hipérbola nunca cruza ye
igual a cero nunca cruza el eje x
y esto también puede ser intuitivo
porque si vemos que con esta
aproximación donde x tiende a más menos
infinito vimos que siempre teníamos este
más 4 aquí y también vimos que cuando x
se vuelve super grande o super negativa
esto tiende a importar menos y menos
pero esto será siempre ligeramente más
grande que este número principalmente en
el cuadrante positivo en el cuadrante
positivo la hipérbola siempre será
ligeramente más grande que la cim total
y cuando tomamos la raíz cuadrada
positiva cuando tomamos la raíz cuadrada
positiva siempre será más grande que
cualquiera de las dos así en total e
igualmente cuando tomas la raíz cuadrada
negativa siempre será un poco más
pequeña que ambas así en total porque
este número va a ser un poco más grande
que este número y cuando tome la raíz
negativa va a ser un poco más pequeña
que la siento está no sé cuál de estos
dos métodos sea más intuitivo para ti
tal vez sólo el hecho tú sabes probando
cuando x es igual a 0 y cuando llegue es
igual a 0 y ver cuáles puntos obtienes y
ver entonces qué o estoy en un tipo de
hipérbola vertical o en una horizontal
dejaré este vídeo hasta aquí y haré otro
vídeo donde realmente traslade la
hipérbola trasladar no es diferente a
trasladar en una elipse o círculo es
solo ya sabes ye menos algo al cuadrado
y x menos algo o más algo al cuadrado y
eso te indica dónde trasladar el origen
esta hipérbola claramente está centrada
en el origen de cualquier modo te veo en
el siguiente vídeo